les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ont malheureusement augmenté dans la
région métropolitaine à Montréal le
nombre de voitures augmente les GES
aussi au grand mot les grands moyens
laver l'annonce qu'elle piétonnisera un
quadrilatère du Vieux Montréal le vieux
Montréal on veut que ce soit le royaume
des piétons actuellement quelques rues
sont réservés aux piétons pendant l'été
le quadrilatère dont on ignore pour
l'instant les contours verra le jour en
après consultation avec entre autres les
commerçants dont certains apprécient
déjà la piétonisation de la rue
Saint-Paul c'est beaucoup plus festif
lorsque les gens se promènent à des
amuseurs publics donc ça crée vraiment
un engouement parce que les gens ils
veulent être en famille il y a beaucoup
de sécurité pour le chiffre d'affaires
est-ce que c'est bien oui oui
certainement
pour les piétons rencontrés l'annonce
est reçu avec beaucoup d'enthousiastes
pour profiter des terrasses pour pouvoir
déjeuner tranquillement sans bruit sans
pollution c'est forcément mieux quant
aux automobilistes on se questionne
les automobilistes qui a à Montréal je
comprends pour les piétons mais
[Musique]
plus au nord la ville veut réaménager le
grand boulevard Henri-Bourassa
inspiré du modèle de la rue Washington à
Chicago ou des voix sont réservées pour
le transport collectif et les vélos pour
les environnementsalistes ce sont des
pas dans la bonne direction la vision
limbonne maintenant ça prend aussi les
autres gouvernements qui viennent aider
à Montréal qui viennent aider Montréal
pour développer entre autres le
transport collectif le transport actif
on aurait pu s'attendre à une mise en
œuvre dès 2023 malheureusement on est
obligé d'attendre en 2024 avec un
quadrilatère seulement
on devrait accélérer cette mise en
oeuvre là le transport est responsable
de 40% des émissions de GES au Québec
dans des plaisent aux automobilistes une
transition écologique nécessite
forcément de s'attaquer à démesure afin
de réduire le nombre de voitures sur les
routes ici Elisa serrer Radio-Canada
Montréal